[Music]
cars from more than ten decades on a
racetrack that winds around Goodwood
house in southern England visitors come
from around the world including Pink
Floyd drummer Nick Mason a big fan of
fast cars and professional racecar
drivers like Nico Rosberg this is the
first time I've come back to England as
a world champion and it's really nice to
see everyone here again this is a huge
event reason event air yeah great cows
great people it's a great celebration of
motor racing the Italian sports car
manufacturer Ferrari is using the event
to celebrate its 70th birthday
collectors from all over the world have
brought their most beautiful Ferraris
spanning seven decades to Goodwood the
Ferrari owners simply love their cars
with that distinctive Ferrari emblem
it's almost like a drug you know and I
think the longer you're involved with
them so the more it sort of grows into
you yeah I'm a bit biased but I'd like
to think that every sort of car
collector would dream of the ideal
garage being filled with Ferraris James
Cottingham drives a 1971 Ferrari 365
gtb/4 decades he's been searching for
valuable Ferraris but here he sees cars
that he's never seen before like a 1993
f40 it's really nice to see one because
you don't see them very often big car
the very first Ferrari was built in
Maranello Italy in 1947 when Enzo
Ferrari ran the company and it's on view
here in Goodwood Enzo Ferrari loved car
races he built a lot of race cars and
the vehicles he designed for everyday
driving were also quite sporty I was
lucky to know Enzo I raced for him for a
year and a half and I got to know him
and he was an individual man everybody
else hides behind a board of directors
he was Enzo on his own a high point of
the festival a sculpture crowned by a
Ferrari was unveiled in front of
Goodwood house Lord March dedicated the
sculpture to his friend Bernie
Ecclestone
who made Formula one the most successful
car racing series in the world Goodwood
has had close ties to both Formula One
and Ferrari for decades there's always
been a passion for Ferrari I mean fries
raced here in the 50s
invited drazi at the race and Bernie
Ecclestone discovered his love for
vintage Ferraris in Goodwood the top
quality of their chassis Xand engines
make these cars seem new even after 50
years a 1962 Ferrari 250 GTO can cost 40
million euros today as a production
model I would say the 250 GTO especially
for a Rhodes Road usable car is the most
valuable car in the world well admit
suddenly the most thought of an known
car Nick Mason is the proud owner of
this GTO Ferraris fetched the highest
and most stable prices on the vintage
car market that's because of their image
an image that their prominent owners are
polishing constantly there's a rarity to
it it's like a great Fender guitar or
Stradivarius violin you know it's a tool
really it's not a piece of art but it's
a tool that embodies so many special
things
Ferraris are fun and they're most
certainly collectible and their market
value is always boosted by an appearance
at the Goodwood Festival of Speed
[Music]